[Music]
alejandro
what have you done
during this pandemic
well
i have to tell you the pandemic came
just such a huge shock right for
everybody for everybody and the chess
world was affected in many ways i have
to say some positive and some negative
of course as soon as the pandemic hit
everything was cancelled
right we had all these plans the us
championship was about to come up
in 2020 we had a lot of team tournaments
going on it was the pan
american
national championship pan ams are april
right actually pan ams are in december
and we qualified for the final four the
national championship that's what i
meant the national championship for the
universities in san luis university was
of course qualified ready to compete
with the best here
and suddenly
we just didn't have the ability to
travel
all the time all
cancelled wow that was a tough blow but
luckily for us in our sport we were able
to move it online okay very nice
we weren't able to manage to make the
final four online so that was canceled
as well but slowly slowly we started
getting more tournaments and i'm happy
to say that missouri has two world
champions not only that st louis
university win the world university
blitz championship
but mizzou missouri university
headed by christian carrillo they want
the rapid protection
congratulations so
you guys ended up being world champions
right
so cool a tournament that had never been
hosted before because of the pandemic
feed it was well we can host it online
that makes it kind of easy nice very
nice the st louis university your
foreign students
they must have been terribly impacted in
all kinds of ways they had a tough
decision to make of course there were
lockdowns around the world and some of
them were unable to travel to america
okay
they weren't able to attend classes in
person
everything was moved online they had a
tough decision to make do you want to
take online classes from here or do you
want to do it from your home country and
some of them were just unable to travel
at all even if they had the desire to
come to america we had visa issues we
were closed borders it was just
difficult for them and i have to say it
was a very very tough first semester
there with the pandemic and slowly
everything was moved online we were able
to get zoom meetings we were able to
move all of our classes online i met
with everybody through skype or zoom
and then you had something soon then you
had some students that may have been
trapped on campus like they can't
necessarily go home or can't necessarily
return to their own countries so they
had to stay in the dorms and right we
hadn't
wasn't
too pleasant either right oh we had
quarantine periods a couple of my
students actually they had to quarantine
at a hotel for 14 days without leaving
the room oh dear just to come to
university yeah oh my gosh it was very
hard
but
things are easing up a little bit we do
have tournaments now which is
that's a big plus right a lot of my
students they were norm hunting okay
they were trying to get that elusive
grand master title they had a whole
schedule planned i'm gonna get my first
norm here my second norm there and my
next crack is going to be there
that's all smashed away it's all
snatched away and they had to just be
patient and keep their skills sharp by
playing online
because well there were certainly no
norm tournaments right right so
a lot of them
they said i have to wait i'm gonna make
myself an online specialist for now but
it's just not the same exactly online
unlike over the board
over the board i can play you a
four-hour game oh it's gonna have it
where it's gonna be a cool game and i'm
gonna learn a lot i am not going to play
you a four-hour game online i i may play
41-minute games online but somehow
online chess is not conducive to
classical chess it's more blitz
it's the arena for blitz and rapid and i
think i get this asked a lot especially
by amateurs like why don't grandmasters
play classical chess online why don't
they it's boring
it's just straight up boring i mean if
you have a tournament and you're playing
for something of course you add to the
mix and we had several classical
tournaments online
during the pandemic but it doesn't have
that feel it's just weird when you're
not in front of the board i can't see
you i can't make you uncomfortable
right the clock is ticking
no trembling hand you know and somehow
when you're playing classical chess
online you have to sit in front of the
computer for 35 minutes waiting for your
opponent to make a move right
it's just like time's not passing right
and somehow when you're in front of the
board 35-minute thing by your opponent
passes in a snap it can easily go easily
so it's just not conducive and i think a
lot of grandmasters don't like it and
some of them just flat out refuse
exactly i i'm not interested at all in
classical chess but
online
but then it's the funny part the
opposite happens
when we are at over the board tournament
uh we we just had the rapid and blitz
which i really really enjoyed but i'm
even more looking forward to the
sinkville cup which is a classical time
control where the players really
sit down
and they carefully craft their plans i
have to say that i'm a huge fan of rapid
chess specifically i think it's this
wonderful mix of fast but also something
that can be explained to the public we
have time to go through the games and
explain their combinations and their
thought process and they still have the
time to calculate brilliancies right but
there is no substitute for classical
chess right it just has this magic where
you see these brilliant preparations
where you see that every move needs to
be precise and of course the level of
chess is so high now that yes we do see
a significant amount of draws yes we do
see a lot of games peter out but that
magic of this brilliant classical chess
it really can't
be explained and it cannot be replicated
in any other format right
uh for me i just have to say that i like
the grand chess tour a lot this hybrid
format this combination of blitz and
rapid in a in a contained tournament
then the classical the only thing to my
mind
that is missing about the grand chess
tour
we need more events we do need more
events that's it but they are coming we
do have more and more events planning
the grand chess tour and we've had so
many join now we have traditionally the
paris tournament i think that was such a
great addition to the tour and we're
going to have so many coming up but i
have to agree with you the hybrid i love
it you have the best players in the
world
not just in classical not just in rapid
and blitz you have to prove that you're
good at every format to be able to win
the grand chester and i think that's
what's made every tour winner so far
stand out absolutely
well thank you yasser absolutely again
dude let's go
we're in the park it's time to make a
hustle
oh
i know this one yeah i know this one
no
don't do it
oh
surprising me there
oh man i hate those hot cacitos